how to make matters even worse similar
to Trump Joe Biden is now under
investigation for his mishandling of
documents for decades Biden left a trail
of classified material in multiple
locations including multiple private
offices in a cardboard box in his garage
but as far as we know the doj has not
even convened a grand jury against Joe
that case appears to be going nowhere
now here with reaction all of this is
author of the best seller trial of the
Century Fox News legal analyst Greg
Jarrett also best-selling author of the
book get Trump Harvard Law Professor
Alan dershowitz and Professor I mean you
know if this is true in other words that
this indictment is coming I'm going to
bet every dollar that I have
that this is not going to be an
indictment about classified material
because the immediate comparisons will
be about Hillary Clinton and the July
2016 press conference of Jim Comey and
he said no reasonable prosecutor would
prosecute and she did have top secret
classified information we have no Dow
Joe Biden had it at four separate
locations as I recall so they'd make
that comparison so it seems to me that
it won't be about classified documents
which means that in the process of
investigating this some process crime
probably came up in their minds and they
went forward with that that's my guess
you're the legal Professor I'm not
you're a great guesser A plus uh in my
book
exactly that that they would not go
after him on the possession of
classified material but they would try
to concoct some process crime
obstruction of justice but let's
remember that citizens of the United
States are not obliged to cooperate with
investigations that are designed to get
them they can do everything in their
power through their lawyers to obstruct
that is to plead the Fifth Amendment to
plead this privilege that privilege to
make a motion to uh suppress material
they cannot have across the line from
legal obstruction to Illegal obstruction
now that line is very vague it talks
about corrupt intent and it's so easy
for a partisan prosecutor to say that
legitimate fifth sixth Fourth Amendment
defenses that are supposed to be raised
by defendants have morphed into illegal
obstruction of justice this sounds to me
like it may be another brag indictment
another indictment that doesn't pass the
shoe on the other foot test that would
never never be directed against a
political friend but only a political
enemy and it really endangers our system
of justice which is supposed to be
politically neutral not politically
motivated so I fear for our system of
law enforcement I fear for it as a
liberal Democrat who voted against
President Trump I don't care about
politics I care about the Constitution
and that's being violated so we can't
get you on on the crime that we think
that you're guilty of Greg Jarrett but
we're going to go after the fact that
you might have obstructed in our
investigation
um now let me ask you when Hillary
Clinton deleted those 33 000 emails with
bleach fit and then remove SIM cards and
then had blackberries and iPhones
destroyed with hammers wouldn't happy
the very definition of obstruction to
you
it's absolutely obstruction yeah sure
it's obstruction of justice and she
stated thanks to James Comey uh but this
is a consistent pattern the left has
weaponized the legal system and their
current Avatar is Merrick Garland you
know scorned as a Supreme Court Justice
he launches a Vengeance campaign against
Donald Trump whom he blames and I you
know I think that Garland is the most
partisan attorney general in history who
corrupted the Biden doj and the FBI
selective prosecution to punish
political enemies but he runs a
protection bracket for uh Joe Biden and
his son you know Garland has taken a
dispute over documents that's governed
exclusively by a civil statute the
presidential records act and Garland has
decided I'm going to criminalize it by
contorting the law but then he discovers
oh gee Joe Biden did my boss did the
same thing okay now I'm going to shift
to destruction claiming that Trump
wasn't Cooperative the professor is
absolutely right he doesn't have to be
cooperative under the law especially
Sean since it was the stated opinion of
the doj that a former president can take
whatever he wants under the records act
for 10 years that was the standard
endorsed by a federal judge in
Washington but Garland abandoned it
because it's Donald Trump his problem is
that obstruction requires a corrupt
purpose the Supreme Court has defined
that immoral depraved or evil intent
well where the hell is that evidence I
mean if Trump honestly believed he was
entitled to the documents under the ACT
there is no corrupt purpose no
obstruction
and if we look at it you know
Professor if we look at you know the
possible or pending indictment of Hunter
on issues involving taxes and lying on a
gun application that is a far cry from
what is truly being alleged isn't it and
that is whether or not there were go
ahead yes sir whether or not there was
pay to play or go ahead
you know that that's clearly correct
this certainly is today enough probable
cause so that if there were a republican
attorney general who as as political as
this justice department there would
certainly be an investigation based on
probable cause of deep corruption by
Hunter Biden now whether it involves his
father or not is an investigative matter
you don't believe sources to prosecute
you believe them to open an
investigation and there should be an
investigation there's enough smoke there
to justify the belief that there could
be fire but let's not jump to
conclusions either way I don't believe
in weaponizing the justice system either
against Republicans Or democrats but
there's certainly enough weaponization
either Professor I want equal justice I
want equal application and I don't see
that here
I agree with you I agree with you yeah
Greg I'll give you the last word on this
um we're taught what they're talking
about involving Hunter is the
low-hanging fruit this these were the
easy indictments they could have had you
know two years ago
um but they didn't go there and now
maybe do they use you know low-hanging
fruit for Hunter to kind of mitigate the
fact that they're going after Donald
Trump the leading Republican candidate
for the for the uh for the presidency
yeah I mean that's the inexorable
conclusion from any reasonable person
who's been paying somewhat attention a
five-year long investigation and no
criminal charges uh you know there is
political protection and partisan uh
influence being exerted here I think by
the FBI as well as the Department of
Justice if Hunter Biden is charged at
all and I am skeptical uh it'll be
relatively minor and it will ignore his
larger suspected influence peddling
schemes that implicate Joe Biden as
complicit I mean you outline some of it
in your monologues just look at the
laptop documents that incriminate Joe
Biden as an active participant as well
as a beneficiary yeah but as I said
before they are both protected while
Trump is targeted hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube age and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else